all right pippy
welcome back
thanks for inviting me back I didn't
know how to dress up a little prettier
for you this time yeah you look great
you look great I didn't know who would
be showing up when we when we when we
arranged to meet this morning Sunday
morning I didn't know if you were going
to show up as
pippy or John or maybe even baby well
you have these multiple personas I do I
think it's uh
Like A coping skill that I've used I
realized more and more uh as as I get
older you know I just
love to delve into a fantasy world I
think it is my way of coping with the
the bad things that happened to me when
I was growing up and you're uh currently
you're one of your partners or your
partner lady Shem
um and that does that video and those
follow-up videos exist only on my
subscription channel so some of the
viewers may not know about your other
persona as baby oh okay well
and and John as well I think that that
was also on that channel yeah sorry
street name so do you have uh is it lady
sham told me that you have multiple
personality disorder
I don't yeah
um I think it's really just something
that I use as a tool to uh
detach from my my reality and uh you
know find a new idea I mean putting on a
costume is like a
I mean if there are people who do uh
furries I don't know if you've ever
heard of them but they even they've kind
of found a way to sexualize it but
basically they are dressed up like a
mask like you might see at Six Flags or
any of uh like a mascot like a person
that might be standing outside waving at
cars for like a uh you know tax
accountant or something like that but uh
there's the first time I ever saw it was
up north in San Francisco
um uh it's just all these it's like a
group of people and they're all dressed
up in these mascot things and you can't
tell what gender you're I mean unless
the costume is particularly uh
form-fitting or something like that but
it's just you know it's a furry costume
it's usually fluffy and I mean I guess
it's open for interpretation as far as
like uh if you want to be Chewbacca or a
famous character but it's a whole big
thing I mean people spend thousands of
dollars on the that gear and how many
different personas do you have
because I've met
pippy and I've met John and baby who
doesn't speak yeah well I just did
didn't want to give myself away I guess
but now the cat's out of the bag so uh I
just do to
but uh I like to play dress up you know
so um
even though I'm just you know called
pippy I might look very you know go for
a very different look you know um
I usually I tend to like the gothic look
you didn't come in here maliciously
trying to trick me
no it was just who you were
yeah well I I know it's probably
difficult to understand but I think what
you do
ah it's so diff I mean you talk to
people that come from
so many different walks of life and I
think we're all very damaged in
different ways just based on the things
that I've that I want that I watched I
didn't realize how big your channel was
or how much of a reach it had and uh
it's it's really inspiring because I
think there's a lot of people who just
go through life unheard and out without
um
even knowing how to advocate for
themselves or even ask for help and and
I've been one of those people and I just
I feel like there's more life behind me
now than there is ahead of me and I want
to make what
whatever's coming be as uh
endurable as possible I mean we're
collectively all of us the human race
are facing
maybe even uh Oblivion I mean there's so
much it's like it feels like a ticking
time bomb and then coming down to Skid
Row here like this seeing the people
that are just desperate and scrambling
and
uh garbage all over the streets it's
just chaotic and it's I just don't want
that to be where I can go and I feel
like I'm capable of going there it just
seems that uh
I'm holding on to all these things from
people that that people inflicted on me
when I was and now they're gone they're
they're dead I'm never I'm not hearing
from them again yet they're still
impacting me so that's why I don't want
to continue in the in that direction
and I'm seeking help now
um
uh I told you I kind of a chronic
kleptomaniac except like shoplifter and
I got caught
uh recently and lucky for me the person
who who caught me let me go but with the
stern warning uh it turned out he was uh
he is in recovery himself he's a former
convict
um the the store that I was I don't know
if I should tell you the name of the
store it's a big a big box store but
they have uh a program where they hire
felons are people who have you know been
can have a prison record more or less so
uh I think they probably get some
tax breaks or whatever for doing that
but he was one of these people had been
a convict and
told me that he was he was going to let
me go this time
but he made me go to his church with him
and there are a Hispanic Congress but
they speak English so uh
so I went to uh
Apostolic Mexican church with him and uh
listen to that I mean I've
I've never had a true kind of spiritual
belief but as it just because you know
of the abuse I encountered from people
that were supposed to be religious uh
leaders and stuff like that so
I've been very
reluctant to uh
dive into that world or to put put a lot
of faith into us in and who hasn't read
all the stories about all the priests
molesting the kids I mean it's it's
almost synonymous like it's like a joke
but I think
everybody has a fundamental need to
believe in something bigger
because
what else is there and and I feel like
that's that's something that happens as
you get older uh it just happens
naturally
um I was just always so jealous of other
people and you know
they used to have they look so pretty
they have all the nice clothes and
beautiful car it seems like their lives
are wonderful and
it looks like it but you never know I
mean then then they'll commit suicide or
something like that so I know now that
you can't
old cliche judge a book by its cover you
know a lot of people put on
put on a show I put on a show so I mean
I I'm
I'm trying to get on the path to getting
better
I told you I'm an alcoholic and uh
went to recovery but I
it got too religious frankly it got to
be uh I guess I got bored
I think what happened with me
um
my addictive inclinations whatever they
may jump around so uh
say uh I'll get alcohol out of the
picture somehow then comes kleptomania
and then comes hoarding then comes over
E I mean
I just I get so frustrated with myself
because it's like I can't I don't have
an off switch and some you know being a
being a baby being in drag that's a
little bit that's an off switch in a way
difficult it is is maybe to understand
but I think
everybody has a need for that in some
way and they they find it in whatever
ways they can
and this is what I found you know
playing dress up in costumes and no it's
important I think for an addict to have
an off switch because that's I I
remember I mentioned this I think in one
of the other talks
I went to some
Gamblers Anonymous meetings in Vegas
once
and
one of the people in the meeting spoke
up and saying you know I
it took me years to realize that I have
an on switch
but I don't have an off switch
and that explains like gambling so
beautifully and it oh I think it
explains a lot of addictions or so if
you found something even if it's
dressing up like you do
that helps you turn it off that's that's
a great tool or another thing that says
that people say a lot is like one is too
many and the Thousand is not enough
meaning of course with alcohol you might
one things might be cute for a minute at
one maybe two oh two three and then it
just escalates and that the same is true
with everything that I do you know like
uh you know all that cherry pie was good
I'll have another I have a whole pie now
you know so uh it's it's maddening and
uh I actually got to the point where I
was so low you know kind of suicidal
even that uh I and I've started taking a
medication now and just it's only it's
only been like a week and I already feel
the difference because
um is is that that kind of a metaphor of
falling down a well or a dark hole that
it's so hard to pull yourself out of
that hole
and then you know the circumstances that
are around you feel like they're closing
in sometimes and you
you don't have to look far to see the
despair in the world and you can latch
onto it I think
it's a kind of an empathy
that everybody has I I particularly have
it and I think it bothered to the point
where it's a bother and
I mean I see people out there on the
street I don't want that like to life to
be my I don't want to be that live that
way but I I have to ask myself how did
it happen what led to that and what
could
lead me to that
I don't have a family structure I don't
have a lot of the things that
people fall back on the abuse that you
went through as a child that that was
sexual abuse
yeah it was both also you know verbal to
um that went on for how long
uh
multiple people over multiple years
actually there was this one person
um
I was probably about 13
and the times are so different because
we didn't
have the kind of information connection
that we did and I feel like he came into
town because he was running from another
state where he had gotten in trouble
probably and he met he was also he was
in the church but he was also a motel a
manager of a motel and
this was the 80s so uh he uh he started
right he would show me pornographic
videos which were not as putting nothing
like we have today I mean he had a
little portable video player and he
would show me pornographic tapes asked
me how um that you're trying to make me
feel with eyebrows all that sort of
stuff you know
and then you would ask me what
how it Advanced I wasn't getting
sexually Etc and so uh that would lead
so I mean I was aroused by the tapes and
all those things so I bet there is a
tremendous amount of shame that came
with it I knew I couldn't talk he told
me I couldn't talk he was married to two
kids
and um
so that went on for
about a year and I think he had other
people
that boys probably
that would come I would swim at the
hotel at the motel that he managed and
uh then he just left town so
I think he got out of town before it got
too and he and he's probably dead by now
because that would have been what 1983
and I don't know if he ever got caught
but uh
there's just so many predators out there
and uh I think what happens to you
you
you can develop those traits yourself
it's a toxicity that can kind of pass
itself down the line or whatever my dad
died young so I didn't have much of a
father figure in my uh
my mom was very bitter about her
situation in life I think she
she didn't want the kids and then he my
dad's one of one of the kids so uh not
only did he leave her with kids he left
and died and you can't blame somebody
for dying or whatever but she resented
them I think because she
we're Eastern European I think we're
inclined to be pessimistic so I know
now that I'm
the an older age
I would have represented
kids like that I mean I think I I my my
go-to was resentment jealousy that's
something that I
did have have had to face with uh with
recovery and uh yeah but back to you
what you were saying about
the the the Predator that you had as a
child I mean I'm sure something probably
happened to him when he was a child yeah
I mean I think yeah he kind of traded
down from generation to generation yeah
that's what I think this information you
scratched the surface you see that it
all comes to Bear uh you know like think
about the original sin or you know think
about all the people who lived and died
before we ever were born and the wars
and the violence and the just the tumult
of life
I think it comes back to us you know it
Cycles back and that's why it takes a
lot of work sometimes to
remove yourself from that and to be
aware that it's there I mean when I
start getting my dark
uh depression uh
all I want to do is sleep so I have to
uh break that cycle and not isolate um
the place where I live I kind of I have
to actually I only have two people there
it used to be three and uh
I mean I'm not a caretaker for them but
I I'm sort of the house monitor of sorts
so I have to uh
and they one is a very
probably early dementia elderly woman
and the other is a schizophrenic who is
uh
wow really an energy vampire that
because she obsesses on ID she's also
hyper religious to like like insane
religious and uh
I don't want to
judge anybody for being religious but
this is a kind of a Mania and she'll
obsess about something that you know
people have been divorced and
she's
well she'll probably never see this I
can't but I I think she's just you know
wrestling with her her sexual identity
and she's always asking me all these
personal questions and
I just say you know that's not something
that you need to know but
so I mean the way the house is divided
up in four
different rooms and I'm in like the
garage area so you're you're older as I
am do you think
that these problems
like what happened to you in your
childhood and what's all the mental
illness and everything that's going on
in our world do you think it's gotten
worse over the years or we're just more
aware of it now
I think it's definitely gotten worse
because
speaking for myself I think the
triggering factors are more evident and
prevalent and
well there's studies that are going on
now I mean the social media world the
the inundation that we have with the
media and every uh well you you know
your generation would remember like me
do you remember when we used pagers and
remember when computer games are like
Pac-Man or I mean like the 80s it seems
like a golden age now an era of you know
like
that but by looking at it now it's like
oh my God so primitive the very first uh
Atari or something like that so I think
everything is really escalated and my
mom used to tell me that time moves
faster when you get older and when
you're a kid you don't believe it but
it it's true it's
uh 10 years is really it's like a blink
of an eye and I mean you think about
geological time and how you know
icebergs Mount things like that but
our lifespans our human lifespans are
really even if we live to be a hundred
that's not a very long time no compare
compared to
the the
forests in the oceans and rock forming
all these things that are there for
Millennia but
we're very destructive species the Earth
would be a whole lot better without us
on it yeah you know what maybe that's
what's that where the invasive species
were the fleas that need to be uh shed
because we're uh we're causing we're
getting we're out of control
we're doing too much destruction no
respect there's I think there's a whole
lot
of disrespect in general now you must
see it too I mean on
there used to be I guess the term is
social contract or whatever where just
basic human dig you know let me walk by
and live my life you walk by you live
your life but people don't do they don't
even respect that anymore they uh they
break into your car they will throw
things at you they could possibly pee
and pee on you I've seen it happen uh I
can't had a close call myself somebody
just like whipped it out and it's like
it's just uh
I don't know no no man there's no
respect or anything I mean granted
they're probably
intoxicated in some way but still it's
just like I feel like it just escalates
and then because when you get victimized
by that you inevitably are gonna be
responding and so I mean it's like the
yeah the negative the step the negative
steps perpetuate and yeah it just when
you when you're around
all these people that are so desperate
and clinging and uh hostile you're bound
to be affected by that so
that's one thing about being out in the
desert right now I
less people
what's been the best time of your life
remember your happiest
um probably uh in my in my early 20s
because I was everything was new I was
better looking in better shape but
I didn't have a serious I mean I guess
the alcohol problem was coming but I
mean it was probably already there all
along but
um
the way I grew up I think I just had a
lot of fear about I was already harassed
a lot for being a [ __ ] and being a
feminate and not really being a
good boy so I had a lot of
guards in place I didn't want to let my
hair down or but when I came to a bigger
city like Atlanta was the closest Big
City to where I grew up so uh that was
like La La Land a kid in a candy store
you know I was young and pretty and
people wanted to have sex with me and
buy me drinks and he'd give me drugs and
I never got
super into the drugs and I've seen so
many people who did and boy the
consequences are not pretty years down
the line
I mean look I guess we think about rock
stars and child stars and people who
had a
a raucous ride to fame and you know they
crash and burn that happens to everybody
so
I don't think
well in my day I think math was the most
destructive drug there was and
now there's probably something even
worse that maybe bad salts or the the
things that get
they get noticed you know when people
become a raving lunatic zombie yeah
there'll be something new on the market
in the next year or two yeah well I mean
like I think bath salts was what the one
that I remember the most about the guy
who became sort of a
he bit off somebody's face in Florida
you remember that they can't they call
them into Miami cannibal but I mean wow
what kind of
what kind of uh transition if fentanyl
doesn't kill off everyone then yeah I
mean it's terrifying I I I I fear one of
my biggest fears is losing my my mind
and doing something like that you know
that uh
hopefully that will never be a
possibility I think that the worst thing
anybody can ever do is sit on it sit on
a stew in their juices like you always
hear about people oh he was a quiet man
then he killed every year and killed a
bunch of people out of there a lot of
those people turns out they're loners
and they sit they have these things
feeding their minds and
I think we see more of that now I think
our culture is set up so probably made
worse of course by the covid
um
regulations where everything is going
online and you don't you don't
physically yeah you know I think I think
a lot of our problems stem from
childhood and the families have broken
down from what they were back in the 70s
or 60s or 50s yeah you know families
were
the
the framework the groundwork you know
the the foundation the foundation is
gone the foundation is gone now so the
kids are being raised you know with very
few
Role Models very few uh Alma yeah even
like parents
well even the school systems are kind of
going for online way of educating people
and I think that lacks so much because
there was a point where AAA meetings
were being held uh online and our
recovery meet all these self-help
meetings all these things uh I guess
better than nothing but uh it still
doesn't
nothing can feel it's like when somebody
takes a video of a live concert
you can't you can see the video but you
it's not it's not as if you were there I
mean the being in in the room makes a
huge difference and I think
that's yeah detrimental of somebody
who's battled loneliness most of my life
you know I feel like it leads to a lot
of self-harm and it's interesting how
these
the abuse that or the neglect or
whatever whatever we went through as
children
that scarred us so often turns into our
sexual
um it colors our sexual uh oh yeah but
it's like people who are into spanking
and bondage exactly
oh totally people have been talking
about that forever and it's a but I
think the baby thing was something that
was maybe too taboo probably because of
the
the diaper
aspect and all that stuff but it's a
role play uh I guess uh if you if both
parties are agreeing to it if no one's
being coerced or no one's getting hurt
yeah I mean like some people would say
why would you want to get spanked why
would you know why so it's hard to
explain to people who don't get it or I
think it probably mirrors what you
experience as a child and you're
probably trying to heal that or fix that
or live it relive it maybe yeah I think
you're right I mean
well we talked about you and all the
people you've talked to 5 000 or more I
mean so many of them are sex workers I
bet yeah they probably all have stories
of childhood abuse maybe all of them
almost all yeah because I've known sex
workers too um I've that
we're very
Happy Hooker all that kind of attitude
like you know I mean women I'm an
empowered woman it's my body and watch
it I mean we're all prostitutes anyway
one in one form or another you know I
can see the reasoning there it's a
transaction
but I think
and that may be fine but then again I
think we need some real Intimacy in our
lives and that's the society today does
so much to prevent that everything is a
transactional
uh relationship now so I'll be your
friend if you provide me with something
yeah it seems like just a pure
unconditional
loving relationship is non-existent now
yeah with pets yeah the way a dog loves
its owner is the way we all should love
each other well that and that that seems
so impossible for people yeah I think uh
because of the dog instantly forgives
everything yeah instantly forgives
everything the ins the survival Instinct
there's you know like the animal world
they
they that's right
not as loyal cats not quite so much but
but you know that's why so many people
are so attached to their dogs and they
would rather have the relationship with
their dog than a human being oh yeah I
mean look at all these businesses that
have sprung like pet supply stores and
stuff like that I mean so people spend
more on a pet than a child in some
instances I bet and uh it's just the dog
knows how to love yeah
well I mean dealing with people is
is very confusing I don't know if you
have children or anything like that but
I mean I think about the mistakes that
were made
when I was growing up but then I'm able
to forgive a lot of that because
what would I have done what would I've
done differently I mean I am
a product of the world I came from I
believe we do inherit our personality
traits from our parents
even people that get have been adopted
they still have a lot of the same
personality traits and I know that for
because the girl I talked mentioned
earlier I haven't met her father several
times he's real
I mean I can see how she turned out to
be
so damaged but he's not been in her life
he's just only recently come back and I
see that there's so many similarities
there it's kind of you know just proves
my my point my theory so
I don't want to be a sad person I don't
want to be a failure in life that's why
I want to change the majority of our
talk today and maybe last time too were
it was a little bit dark
yeah and you're focusing on so I think I
don't want the darkness to Eclipse but
you don't seem like a a sad person
I I well I think I tried to put on a a
happy face if I can but I think with
circumstances make a big difference with
me I mean I'd be happier if I had a a
better place to live and more money and
all the things that people want out of
life but
that's uh where I am today in in my
journey of trying to uh make the most of
the time I have uh people that are not
still with me anymore uh died young they
died fast they lived hard and partied
and they wanted to
to be fabulous all the way to the end I
felt that way too when I was in my 20s
you are look at you Fierce and funny
who's going to tell you you're not
fabulous well that's one thing that's uh
one aspect now is like dressing up and
doing and being in drag was never as
acceptable as it is now I mean kids now
are doing it but uh 20 years ago or more
there was no RuPaul's Drag Race or any
of that stuff so she's done a lot to
make the whole world re or whatever her
pronoun she probably uses the Hebrew
number who's that RuPaul's Drag Race oh
right right all these things that just
turned like drag queens have become a
very mainstream sort of thing so
I guess that that can be fun our world
has changed a lot yeah I think the uh
the things that are considered normal
now would be shocking and terrifying 50
100 years ago absolutely I I think a lot
of younger people have no sense of
History
I've somebody was asked mentioned the
twinkie defense the other like a couple
of days ago and uh this the everybody
else there was so young they had no idea
what that was and I was the only one who
knew and of course the twinkie defense
is the uh
Dan White who who shot Harvey Milk and
uh
about George Moscone claimed that he was
eating too many Twinkies and that's why
he you know he he he went off the deep
end and he killed Moscone and milk so
but all that I mean that was a pretty
pivotal part of history but it's it's
forgotten now hell even a lot of young
kids have forgotten 911 which I thought
was one of the biggest things in in this
Century but
uh there's too much I think there's too
much other news too much Kardashian
Information
Society marches on the the pro yeah the
priorities Have Changed History gets
forgotten and I think that's why we're
saying a lot more unhappy youth
that I think maybe they probably see an
image of an unattainable uh world for
like the people that are showing off and
look at me in my on my exciting Cruise
drinking the finest champagne and
dressed to the T so you feel like that
could never be you it's I could never
live up to that
so it's discouraging because I feel that
way I felt that way before we ever had
social media I know I have an
inclination how everyone gets to see
everyone else's life yeah
it's almost like everyone has a
a publicist or you know like a studio
image an image an imologist maybe is the
term maybe people that lived in poverty
never knew what the
the ultra Rich Live Like and vice yeah
they wouldn't have had they might see a
movie about it or something like that
but you know they don't see people that
are flexing and showing off and all that
sort of stuff so it's an interesting
time yeah yeah it's interesting to me
just
think about what where it will lead us
where it will go because the things that
happen now happen so quickly
um you might remember some of the
stories about like these these children
that become Tick-Tock stars and then uh
they end up killing themselves after at
one you know when they're not even legal
drinking age yet that's happened more
than once
it just escalates and snowballs like
when you get on when you do something
online now it gets seen so quickly by so
many people and
it's actually very it's very simple
stuff too you know a guy riding a
skateboard drinking juice you know it's
not if some somehow that connected and
it turned into a big thing and he became
famous yeah now things things happen
very very quickly now yeah you can
become a meme and and Trends come and go
yeah I I suspect being
Ultra rich and flashing it on social
media and all that will become uncool in
the next five ten years I yeah I think
it's kind of that way now I mean I think
there's a lot of resentment especially
people that are like me who are really
suffering financially I mean it's really
gross to watch well and you think about
you know the price of my gas I could I
almost didn't make it here today Etc or
that kind of so here it's embarrassing
to look at some of these people doing
that and it's like yeah they don't
they're so out of touch and it's exactly
like the old Marie Antoinette let the
meat cake kind of uh attitude if people
even know who that is anymore but you
know that that just a complete uh
disconnect and uh
hmm a distaste for the poor yeah I'm
hopeful that we start to see each other
is more equal
well that would be ideal it might be a
little bit cockeyed optimism but
I mean I think people have been have
lived this way for such a long time that
it's really difficult to to make that
transition for for if if people are
suddenly asked to pay a huge higher
amount of taxes they're going to balk at
that yeah of course but in other
countries where they do pay a higher tax
they get more out of it too I think they
have better social welfare less I I
can't maybe Calcutta but like what other
country
can compare to America with their
homeless population I mean it's it's uh
it's pretty embarrassing
it's unequal and I mean especially in an
industrialized you know a city like this
that's got so much wealth that's just
but the further we get apart from each
other the more it likes to call itself
the greatest country in the world yeah
that's like a whole bunch of different
other countries you know California is
kind of like a whole country all in its
own yeah it is even San Bernardino is
trying to secede from the state
I live in San Bernardino County now yeah
so
you still see your trunk I mean Trump
trump trucks driving around waving their
flags all right yeah
it's it's Southern California too I've
seen him in Southern California there's
the Trump rallies
I think is it Loma Linda or is that
where the Nixon Library is I happen to
be driving through there one day and
there was a big Trump rally I thought
wow I guess this is Republican country
but
you don't expect to see that I think
it's I feel like it's more of a the deep
south Mississippi Alabama kind of thing
not California no California California
gets pretty redneck as you go Inland oh
yeah for sure so I think everybody who
doesn't who doesn't know it thinks of LA
or Hollywood maybe San Francisco but
there's a lot there's a lot more between
those two places so yeah
excellent well Pippi thank you so much
for coming back thank you for inviting
me back you're always fun to talk to you
are too you have a great demeanor I mean
you have such a casual I don't know a
soft boy have you been on the radio do
you do no you have a net a a pleasing
voice oh thank you no I just I just find
everyone interesting
people are especially you but everybody
well I thank you so much and I I'm very
pleased to be be back yeah we'll do
we'll have you in a game okay maybe
it'll be somebody different next time
yeah let's see if I can get get lady
sham to come with me oh yeah we could do
that she's great too she's off on her
adventures right now she's working with
some video video guy I don't know if
they're probably making porn but okay
we'll see